Deanna is with us in Columbus Ohio Merry
Christmas Deanna Merry Christmas babe
how are you doing sir better than I
deserve
how can I help you today yes sir I have
a terrible situation I've made some bad
decisions with money I make about 52,000
a year and I have about $50,000 in debt
I'm being sued by two of the creditors
now and the issue is I have a job that
for which I have to maintain a security
clearance and I've been following you to
clear it up within 30 days so I don't
know if I should try to file bankruptcy
or try a debt management program I've
been to court and it just seems to me a
very long process with the two creditors
and they don't seem to want to work out
anything gets me so I'm sorry if you
filed bankruptcy does not blow your
security clearance um well that's what
I've been told I've been hearing a lot
of mixed information from the job Wow if
a lawsuit blows your security clearance
for non-payment of debt a bankruptcy
definitely blows it yes
so the bankruptcy doesn't solve that
issue so $50,000 in debt on what well 10
of that is a private student loan and
the rest of it is individuals on credit
cards if we're not you have $40,000 on
credit cards yes sir okay what'd you buy
oh yeah you know investor thing I looked
in the closet when I finally reached the
lowest of the low point and I look
around it well where is it I don't see
it anywhere it must just be you know I
don't know what I'd be look at money
it's ridiculous trust me I realize how
ridiculous the situation is now so it's
over a period of years you just been
buying miscellaneous junk right okay yes
Chuck and who has sued you I there is a
city bank but Discover Bank bought us
below the student loans who suit you
yes okay the $10,000 student room yes
sir okay
and who else sued you portfolio Recovery
Associates
on behalf of whom on behalf of GM or
capital one visa yes okay and that was
how much that one is about 8,000 okay
and one of the court dates I'm sorry
when are the court dates Oh February of
next year all right and there they've
called you the court they're in your
city in Columbus
yes sir you don't have any money no
what's your calling is my retirement
what's your car worth it's about $6,000
zero about four thousand and that's in
the fifty thousand he gave me yes sir
okay all right how much is in your
retirement uh about thirty five thousand
right I don't believe in cashing out
retirement except to avoid bankruptcy or
a foreclosure you're on the verge of
losing a lawsuit and you're on the verge
of losing your security clearance in the
process um and so I would file with your
401 K for a hardship and pull enough out
to clear up those two dads
okay and just pay them all okay and then
then what we've got to do from there is
you make sixty two thousand dollars a
year this is doable the rest of it is
and you can work your way through these
debts you need to get the stupid credit
cards out and have plastic surgery yeah
get your neck get you on a written
budget and get your freakin life under
control right yes and how old are you oh
I am 42 I'm gonna maybe for a long time
you sweet
you're sweet I like you well you know we
all get to grow up so now's the time
darling so uh it's a painting about this
growing up stuff so it's time to do it
though all right I'm gonna head I'm
gonna help you cuz this is fun okay
okay would you go through Financial
Peace University is my guest if I give
it to you to learn how to handle money
and get this mess cleaned up I would
love to look and try actually to pay for
it I looked at some older programs on
Amazon
but I wanted to see I pay for the new
ones so yeah you don't want to go though
one the newer means a whole lot better
so an Amazon doesn't have old ones
anyway eBay might but Amazon only sells
the new ones um they're supposed to but
anyway the what we're going to do is you
get to go through the classes my guess
that'll be my Christmas gift there's
only two rules one you must attend you
must attend every class and someday when
you're out of debt and doing really well
and somebody else's time to grow up you
buy their class program okay
yes sir all right you hold on we'll help
you out
merry Christmas to you Diana this is the
Dave Ramsey show
you